est-ce que vous avez une phobie vous
attend avec les oiseaux les plumes
d'oiseaux et plus loison patoucha
noiseau n'arrivait pas tu ne la trouve
pas on pouvait parler un petit peu plus
fort je ne peux pas toucher noiseau
d'accord et basse et je sais pas d'où ça
vient mais une fois y en ait qui
rentrait chez moi comment on appelle ça
la plus beau plus + mobile a la phobie
des oiseaux et là vous dire le temps
qu'on tape sur google c'est rien du tout
ça sert à lancer une petite prime des
oiseaux c'est tout simple hobby des
oiseaux c'est la phobie des oiseaux
alors sans déconner c'est la cuite
hutteau phobies et voilà financer
l'ornitho l'avesnois oui et non il me
regarde avec ça c'est l'ornitho phobie
oui ça veut dire ça veut dire moi
j'aimerais que tu pourrais pas peut-être
une plume dans le cul par exemple pour
eux alors et alors alors vous c'est quoi
votre phobie le boulot de tout ce que
vous n'avez pas bosser ah ouais bah j'ai
jamais jamais jamais j'ai jamais
tellement essayons donc je sais pas trop
si j'aimerais ou pas mais le peu que
j'ai fait ici un truc dans le peu que
j'ai bossé m'a pas donné envie de
persévérer dans cette voie donc je pense
que c'est une sorte de phobie pas
remboursés par la sécurité sociale mais
j'aime pas ça vous le savez de façon
j'ai prouvé depuis sa mère pouvait le
match continue - si ludivine le tour
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas pour toi
ah là là ma phobie j'ai la phobie des
pieds je sais pas comment ça s'appelle
allenby c'est le pilier dans ta gueule
aux folles j'ai horreur de ça un touch
avec les pieds ou encore mis les pieds
des bébés deux jours de monbahus est
encore petit ben ouais je déteste ça
vraiment j'ai essayé de vaincre saint
geours avec ma mère vous êtes allés à la
chaussée rien j'essaye d'apporter et
tout lui nettoyer les pieds au deuxième
orteil chats abandonnés gp les jeux tu
ne peux pas le prendre mais le mien oui
mais les airs alors qu'ils avaient
encore les pieds avec des verrues des
oignons des trappeurs bmc le plein dans
les pieds de jean michel herr pense a
les pieds les plus torrides qu'on
connaisse au moins bon je vais bien
michel ça vous dérange pas les pieds
mais du coup ça me dérange
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous avez la ville des monstres des
monstres démence mais c'est quel genre
de monde a regardé la dernière fois que
vous êtes venu à howie non regardez
regardez alors vous vous êtes du genre à
avoir peur dans la vie ou pas du losc
est des trucs qui vous font peur or vous
avez peur oui il ya des trucs qui me
font vachement part oui vous avez déjà
eu très très peur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'allemande a tardé connais j'ai raté de
mener la merci j'en ai gardé uqam et la
transphobie
hamida par les pieds de jean michel qui
paieraient de l'âme vous mettez tout le
monde fuit ouais c'est la page blanche
en fait la patte blanche
j'ai toujours de l'annuaire en fait mais
en fait non mes carnets en fait je note
tout plein de monde tout le temps
le sniper dans des carnets je note tant
de choses des mots des phrases des
intentions d expression je suis hantée
l'homophobe quoi antelme homophobes
entre mendient j'ai la phobie des verts
non-verts louise en 2011
je suis allée acheter une pomme mais
c'est le primeur gelé a suivi croquer le
sauvegarde sont lâchés du chômage c'est
une poche
[Applaudissements]
je descends je vais chez le primeur as
tu besoin de quelque chose pour la
ratatouille de ce soir nos je l'apprends
gelé suis-je la fraude blackrock
elle a un énorme revers de 4 cm il est
passé et je me suis qu'il avait une
drôle de tête le vert ben je venais de
bouffer sata mais depuis on était le
faire sans pet comme ça tu te déshabille
dans le noir par exemple
quoi quoi la maison noire les verts eux
[Applaudissements]
les clowns blancs j'ai la terreur des
clowns blancs ouais parce qu'en plus je
sais jamais si c'est des clowns blancs
qu'on a maquillé ou s'ils sont vraiment
des clowns blancs vous croyez le bien
des messes lula oui ça veut dire georges
galéa l'obstétricien et oui je laisse et
à croûte blanc et le gris nez avec un
héros tout ça le petit direct les jours
de mal à passer en jeu la cua et
chaussures ont du mal à passer
ah non mais en face moi alors racontez
pas donc secteur déclare mme terrisse
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ma partenaire alors ils bossent ici la
terreur c'est sûr mais je suis je peux
alors quoi en plus ça a l'air d'être un
vrai il ya des vagues
tu as donc eu l'idée nous a fais gaffe
ya deux trois coups non je te donne
l'info voilà tu en fais ce que tu veux
quoi picorer
j'ai déjà été clown blanc j'ai fait
l'école du cirque et gère des
maquillages et frère était notre but ce
qu'est ce qu'un nom alors michel jarre
présent que ça vous intéresse c'est le
témoignage voudrait voir parce que
j'aime beaucoup la tête de gilles quand
il raconte sa phobie les clowns blancs
est un ancien n'est plus mais qui a été
je viens de l'imaginer en clown blanc
s'adapter riche lipuma déjà quand normal
il est vivant oui c'est quelque chose
isabelle morini-bosc babu qui met pas
quand une femme se déchausse il me
semble qu'un jour je vous ai entendu
dire à une chroniqueuse armée terme et
et les chaussures je déteste confiance
qu'il est mal temps c'est tout il ne
faut plus mais qui se trame chez skil et
pour ce que je suis ma blessure goléa
stalder tout de suite et vous mettez ce
que vous pensez de jean michel maire aux
snipers
non mais c'est vrai que non j'ai c'est
que c'est caroline ithurbide elle veut
absolument avec pieds nus sur le château
à chaque fois lauréat partout où elle
éleva tes potes benito jeudi chance ou
toi chanceux toi j'aime bien et vengerov
série je suis à l'ancienne donc j'aime
bien voilà côtoyé je vous écoute
quoi payet je vous écoute merci oui
alors sinon moi j'ai alors moi j'avais
la hantise est née des cauchemars
d'enfants de me retrouver nue dans une
foule nombreuse à risque pas
c'est aussi un film et sa société par la
foule parents qui se sont tenues ou jeu
deux fois c'était pas ensemble je pense
que ça va bien c'est aussi le cauchemar
d'un appel - là chef un bon début de
retrait en début d'émission des gones
est bon et que deux indices vraiment
note que sans décote
non non c'est pas et donc oui moi
lorsqu'il y avait pas la foule mais il y
avait quand même des gens c'est un jour
mon chat est passé par la fenêtre et moi
j'essaie dans un forêt de chaussée et le
nom savant rez-de-chaussée mais font
voilà c'est à dire qu'à un faux premier
étage
moi moi m'ont chassé sacré donc je saute
non j'avais sous-estimé la hauteur donc
je n'arrivais pas à remonter et jeux
d'été en petite culotte son match de
couches en petite culotte
d'accord pas mal d'infos je me suis dit
mais il faut que je fasse le tour du
quartier y'a pas à chier je suis pas
chez moi donc il faut que je passe tout
le groupe pour revenir à ma porte
d'entrée et donc et en plus songer tant
que quelque 40 mais arrête
il faut que j'attende que quelqu'un dont
je fais le tour des quartiers et il y
avait quand même des gens dans le
quartier notamment de poules ce trafic
je trouve des cartons d'emballage et je
me les mener devant et derrière design
en assises devant chez moi il y avait un
monsieur est un monsieur d'origine
aviaire est arrivé devant moi il fait
c'est poker perdu
[Applaudissements]
laissant là attendez l'histoire n'est
pas finie mais juste une phrase et il
ajoute je vous jure que c'est vrai ben
vous est emballé mais c'est pas un
cadeau
nous avons fait beaucoup rire cette
partie alors que cette partie là n'a
rien
ils s'entendent pas là pour ça j'ai eu
deux hélas combien est par exemple mais
non tu de vous non la lave ou c'est un
an mais là sans rigoler vous êtes c'est
comme ça franchement ce jour c'est le
titanic de laval l2 non mais sans
arriver à cinq ans groupe allez on va
mettre la musique de titane mathieu
[Applaudissements]
dit jean michel quintin ça très touchant
de rachat une salle d'eau enfin ses
partenaires de mathieu caron maquillage
fait rire alors mes phobies
j'en ai deux les serpents et les femmes
je dis les choses j'ai pas d'anecdotes
bams et direct les gens le serpent il
fallait mais oui pardon
pourtant le serpent et faillite ça prend
des falic minimes où va le renvoyer
isabelle elle radote sa déprime le box à
raconter mais c'est beaucoup voilà alors
mais c'est vrai et badaboum
elle vous écoute vous savez la phobie
des femmes êtes complètement fou quoi
vous êtes complètement ou ceux d'exane
ont de quoi les femmes nues ah oui ça va
être sa famille vous vouliez pécho kelly
je vous rappelle en booking bbc bref
c'est le pouvoir si vous avez de chance
cette phobie sais plus je crois qu'il
nous prend pour des comptes des années